hey everyone welcome back to the e3
stage here at GameSpot I'm your host
Mike McCarty here with tomorrow saying
okay we are gonna be playing super mario
odyssey I'm here with Daniel ory wella
from Nintendo treehouse yes thank you so
much for coming on ah
enough with that okay yeah well thanks
so much for coming on today No thank you
very good I may be on the show yeah we
have a Sarah here also playing Odyssey
off to the sides yeah thank you from
treehouse but yeah let's jump right in
yeah so tell us what we're seeing yeah
so right delivery beginning is actually
the Odyssey that more I'll be able to
travel around he does need to collect
moons which is something not the object
you'll be collecting as you go out to
the game to power that um but here we
are just starting in what's called the
sand Kingdom and what's cool here that
you see those those coins she's grabbing
are actually not the standard coins or
called regional coins right um where you
actually can gather them to purchase
items that might be focused on the Civic
area you're in okay um and this is quite
different visually from what we how did
you get here from new dong see what
directions the Google Maps there yeah
yeah
well this actually touched arena town Oh
what's funny is the developer the
director of the game he visited Mexico
okay on vacation and he then said no I
want this in the game that was kind of
the idea that started it and then it
became this crazy wonderful world
clustering the town that is now here
with ice yes it is frozen yeah you do
notice that we come back out of this cat
crazy cap store will show that more it
had actually freezing cold
so this doesn't mean that you don't say
either like a hub world then we having
to say so that's it's one of the kings
you can go to it's part of the Metro
Kingdom okay you dunk city so there's
still multiple kingdoms to discover so
have a chance to learn later on with you
actually what will be each one is there
a hub world or do you simply keep going
to different location exploring ok so it
looks like are you maybe buying clothes
for warmth right now it's not just
aesthetics it's more aesthetic okay now
but you will just see now Mario in a
moment wearing nice a festive Mexican
outfit okay okay and the cabbie still
functions the same way too with the eyes
or a couple different outfits here on
you can go to classic Mario cap or be
more of an explorer and a whole t-rex
concept you saw in the trailer as well
yes
t-rex so I'm into this now you can go as
the adventuring Explorer that is Mario
presumably you're going to explain where
he came from or has it been just there
the entire way very moment yeah yeah if
you were making that guess we haven't
revealed anything about who Kathy is
where Kathy came from the most part it's
just fun that now Mara has someone else
to go on his wonderful Odyssey adventure
he is happy to join him allow you for
going about Yoshi ha ha ha one in
chrissteele Seto there's a little time
to figure out what's going on right now
this is just Kathy right now to be is
venturing along with as well ok so how
so how does the structure work for you
sides like getting moons that seems to
be one of the objectives right like it
might have gotten stars and older Mario
games like so when you're in this toast
arena town right now Oh II just got one
got weird mood so it's a more freeform
exploring to find them or do you
actually go into the specific kind of
like levels that you'll go through
different came to go into it's very much
like Super Mario 64 like Super Mario
Sunshine where it's more of a sandbox
okay a little bit different than Mario
Galaxy morgog so using each each level
had like a beginning in the very end
right this was meant to be go anyway you
want to explore but within the sandbox
realm um one of the helpers call I
believe HoCo nu WA which is a Japanese
term for miniature gardens no popper and
they built a really intricate garden and
now you can dive explore everything
that's inside of it usually a lot of its
just right in front of you so it's
really cool to get a chance to see what
is going on in each area
yeah and finding different solutions to
each each way to get through it's not
always one way to do it so to figure out
which way you want to go I've saw that
flag if you have is that like the place
to check this pond yeah check mark yeah
we're seeing a lot of stuff happening
with Cappy he looks like a very I'll
tall as well as the possession stuff
that we've seen in the dealers like what
kind of like what abilities do you have
with it so capya Cappy it gives you the
ability to capture different things like
right now the binoculars do to explore
even capture enemies that we show them
the trailer which we'll get to do that a
moment here as well but what's cool yeah
Kathy also can be used using the motion
control especially is the most natural
way to cut it broke happy with using the
joy con but school though you can use
the joy kind of different ways like
putting both in the same direction and
actually spins around you in a circle
like right there
or even if you jump in the air and throw
down like Kathy will actually roll down
on the ground
Wow and it looks like when you throw it
that you can delay the return and also
yes as a platform you can delay a hat
gemwraps
when I was waiting bill taking over and
so like presumably based on what we're
seeing obviously you know you don't just
transform aesthetically into the enemy
or whatever you happen to be mimicking
you actually quatre abilities yeah
you're actually capturing Bullet Bill
and transforming into it so yeah you can
fly around here there's all these
different blocks you could use bullet
goes to break but staring doings played
a little bit she actually knows in the
back side there is a moon over there
yeah there's even a moon to the right
and let's just really cool it this a
little bit different than super mario 64
every time you've got one of the stars
the level would end the surface right
yeah yeah this one is much more about a
really get an area densely full of
moving and now you have to figure out
where you can get them all but you don't
have to kick out a level each time so
you kind of keep exploring because this
possession kind of mechanic does that
mean that the game is naturally a little
more puzzle focused than previous
platform I've had met Mario games Mario
usually there's always been a puzzle it
aspect to all these games as well so
this just does another opportunity with
the Caffey mechanic running something
the developers really picked up on
really early on and really developed it
it's just something they really had fun
with okay it R is yes marketing back to
the homage of the 8-bit if your nose
Temari actually is still wearing the
exact idea we're Super Mario Safari can
you use it
McAfee and endowed okay you can't get
your caffeine here totally cool keep
that grasses in terms of abilities yeah
yeah that's awesome that's like a link
between worlds kind of yeah a little
thing like that a little Africa but it's
actually it's going to be 8-bit aspect
of the the old days in the original one
front and hope it'll be other things to
discover that really touch on that
element as well so you've previous Mario
games recent ones have had an element of
multiplayer in them where we're rich you
know collecting coins 5 second player or
just having two characters on the same
screen is that something we can expect
from oddity right now we have not even
talked about that now but I mean the
switch is that the bigger willing
anytime anywhere with anyone and the two
droidcon right after that so I have to
wait and see what the devs decide to
show it will be a later
can you capture a bullet bill or any
other enemy or form do you capture it
indefinitely or is there a time limit
there it depends on the enemy right now
I mean that is how you discover on your
own sure like wood bullet bill there's a
certain amount of time you can be inside
before bullet bill just explodes right
so going in that scenario as well and
obviously the story had the Mario story
is a classic save the princess is that
the same here just a little bit the same
but if you notice in the trailer
prettiest pictures in her wedding outfit
as was Bowser as was Mario during that
so basically Mario's not trying to stop
Bowser from marrying Princess Peach
right now so they just want to see that
and the new enemies that you saw as well
in the trailer of the brutal z-- are
trying to help figure out what's going
on and that's an enemy you'll get a
chance to experience does that mean that
Mario once he's saved in this game they
get married and that's a wrap for the in
forever
yeah uh what don't you see how that goes
out from there I'm not sure exactly the
story finally Wario's time to shine I
did though
Zoe fun just goes on with that yeah so
it's really interesting when doing hey
and we're talking about earlier you're
in a kind of a hot desert area but
you're kind of getting rid of all the
ice and what's it was great desert yes
it was Mario is actually shivering here
stand still that's enough to discover
two we haven't gotten too much of that
yet but yes you are trying to figure out
why is it cold in here and how can you
help runny people toast arena town solve
the problem okay so is it can we expect
to have similar kind of like somatic
clashes and kind of a juxtaposition in
the rest of the the worlds is that what
it's about kind of sorting out returning
everything to the way it should be it
that's all that's all we're showing this
one so far and then yeah that's the
thing that the figure we're not really
giving too much of the story LM okay
yeah I mean the game's not coming out to
October 27th so yeah 20 of time to still
share a lot of little tidbits of
information and run or story elements
and even more gameplay elements as well
get further into the game also cool this
is great it's like almost like when you
go to this 2d it's rewarding people who
had skills from like the older yeah but
it's even cool could denote in 2d it's
still on a curved surface yeah so you're
still doing that as well um and now from
here this is I got one of them one of
the major moons this is one of the
sometimes each of the each of the
kingdoms might have some major goals and
that was one of them but instead of
kicking out now you just continue
adventuring through the area to the next
to the next own which is a bit more
challenging platforming asset will go
into this
area now next okay I catch that little
light post right there that little beam
of light giving you an idea what your
next mate
what's going on there we'll meet them at
sunglow wise the moai's if Sarah can
survive and get across without a problem
you can see what that looks like as well
it's interesting it seems almost like I
don't want to just compare it to other
games but it seems almost like breath of
the wild kind of went for this freeform
exploration just for the joy of it and
like kind of experimenting for the joy
of it is that what's kind of here as a
major theme of Odyssey it's there people
going to compare them to actually mean
you think of a legend as Ella breath the
while it's that vast world that living
world anything and happy and you can
change but I kind of said this is more
like that miniature sandbox that
miniature garden where everything is
very intricately designed and a lot more
of the elements this one are right in
front of you versus Zelda was more like
I want to go to the mountain way
distance this is more about what can I
get right in front of me right now like
a t-rex yeah okay
we often get t-rex yeah this is this
looks tricky yes yes stereo via
practicing I'd be good yeah no that's
one of my fate this is my favorite parts
of this of this whole kingdom right here
just how it looks and how you're trying
to dodge all these things going on like
he's been diagrammed yeah carefully nice
gothic points you got here now you go to
the moai's nice so it's another thing
you have what's cool though I'm always
have sunglasses but if you can't see
anything drop it down now you can see
the little platter well I'm uh they're
like lenses of truth yeah okay I call
the x-ray glasses work as well okay
that's a great walk animation yeah you
walk a little slower when the glasses
are down too bad maybe I'm imagining X
I'm in a good mood but did the music
just change the music does it does
change based on like eating area that's
awesome area area or when you capture
going to to do the nukes that's always a
really good element is the music even
notice too when we build a trailer that
though it's one of the first times ever
that the music the theme song had words
there is a theme songs were using very
Bayonetta like I was listening to I was
like sounds like the Bayonetta theme
it's really like campy and a little can
we hope you like it look I'm a huge fan
of jazz music - I kind of like that
little life I always like end up
snapping my fingers to it as I'm playing
through that as well so it's really fun
to do that I hope someone captured the
glosses going up and down
then turn into like a deal with a gift
yeah you haven't done them sure some
went to work yeah more she worked for
Nintendo distant marketing for them you
can even run with the glasses off - you
don't have to keep them on and keep
running
just take a risk you might fall over and
die oh man are you in the middle of the
what run animation still no the baby I
hate starting she's fine now you're all
good all right there she goes
yes you like the big earrings are the
best part tonight from the sunglasses
and actually it's the next new chart
here do that if you speak to that
character now and it'd be like what
happened there the moai should our
headlights out yeah black Delaware my
why my hair now the or the character get
to discover that's part of the fun is
just really discovering and exploring
these little sand boxes and finding what
is going on in each area what elements
are there so a question I kind of asked
you before we started was we have these
you know these gardens as you call them
yeah and boxes and you're going through
and they're getting progressively harder
I'm assuming and then you actually get
two new parts the puzzle but between
these sand boxes you know new dog city
or toast arena town how do you get
between these is it something that
you'll just pick from a menu or like I
mean mario64 the whole hub was the
castle they jump paintings is there
something you could talk about in terms
of that in this game sadly I can't talk
about it yet we haven't show yet but
it's going to be relevant to the Odyssey
that's the whole point the oddity is the
vehicle Mario games to get around that
that's why that's what you're gathering
all these moods to power it up um
there's the airship you saw values in
earlier as well so we're heading toward
that area there's almost like a giant
Mario planet head if whatever it was oh
yeah galaxies yes that's the guy up
there
I took off right you do the role Wow as
Mario got any new abilities platforming
wise new spins
well cabbies the big one I mean cabbies
a huge aspect of it um somehow got his
car stuck in here uh can we possess him
no you can't possess him no okay cool
you can try never no nope so they also
an MP test that you can't possess yeah
that's what I get to experiment I mean
there I mean we showed in the shirt and
either there are gonna be certain
characters a new dog city that you can
oh yeah there's always other things to
be finding you'll always be trying to
experiment what you can capture with
using Kathy not using cat and I said
it's put the date on when you what's
that little bug it's just to keep track
of when you've got them okay yeah you
can also take screenshots I mean that's
an aspect to of taking images of your
journeys you're going through it's gonna
be funny to see
how many you got on day one like well
yeah doctor 27 first day we clearly got
in that very very first day when you get
yes now yes never instead the inverted
pyramid here any chance to go through
here a little more bullet bills more 2d
action a little bit children element
tubules here just a moment as well so
it's weird it's almost like maybe the
first time tomorrow not the first time
but assumingly based on the fact you can
possess bullet bill there was there were
more than one ways to get through
puzzles now right yes yes and that's
interesting because mario is always
about that fine-tune design not to say
that's not here but now it's almost like
those uh you know like the emergent
gameplay you can do more if you can do
something more one way and zelda or
anything oh that's awesome yeah
definitely they really and that's what
the the dev team really talked about too
is that they're really excited that
there are different elements of the game
here they've created yeah and they know
they've come up with certain solutions
and you are multiple solutions but
they're really curious to see when they
really let this game go out and go out
in the public yeah how different will
people find other things they never even
thought of or try to discover ways what
you've seen like even in legends all
breath a while like people come with
most intricate ways to solve share yes
and I'm really curious to see what who
are gonna discover when they start doing
this yeah speedrunners completionists
people just having fun casually because
like oh my god you know I could do that
even ways like the developers didn't
intend ya necessarily don't like but
yeah it didn't like plan for I'm so
excited to see let speedrunning
community' grab this cuz I'm trolling
all these items and weapons and happy to
carry gas that's I'm really excited to
for this at all ideas because even
people yes there are people here to be
huge speedrunners and I love how the
bullet bill goes from to you did yeah ah
but yeah I know the speedruns will have
their opportunity stuff that's fun on
their own but even then they're still
always playing to do like I'm more of a
completionist personally everyone's be
their own thing I'm gonna try get every
single moon shard or moon that's
available in each Kingdom similar I did
when I played Mario 64 I'm really so
excited that also yeah are we going to
be seeing other familiar Mario
characters ways where is the we yet
that's that's right we're hoping to see
what's coming up in the future so far um
the only we can say a new dog that you
do see Pauline yep yeah Pauline is there
around that's a familiar character and
goes a Princess Peach Bowser and Pauline
so far I've been shown awesome well here
we are getting to the final boss cool um
I think unfortunately oh we're out of
time that's fine these are the poodles
yeah these are the enemy your
yes and you actually fight against
Harriet the female character right there
right okay but in front of time sorry
oh yeah anyway I guess John Luke we
gotta close out oh yeah Daniel thank you
so much for coming on Sarah thank you
for playing great uh yeah if you're
watching from home we are gonna be
demoing all we can keep streaming we are
going downstairs to our other stage soon
they're gonna be playing a breath of the
wild actually cam instead we're gonna be
doing this like at the two joy conjuring
oh yeah so you're there keep watching
for that and then we'll be back up here
later on with some more game demos and
developers see you then bye